schon in naher zukunft wollen wir
menschen den mars besiedeln doch dafür
sind noch einige herausforderungen zu
bewältigen
wie sollen beispielsweise lebenswichtige
rohstoffe wie sauerstoff wasser und
treibstoff auf den roten planeten
gebracht werden unmöglich
jetzt lüftet die nase an einer
wirklichen lösungen für genau dieses
problem autonome roboter sollen demnach
aus lokalen ressourcen nämlich der mars
erde wasser sauerstoff und treibstoff
produzieren klick zum zweiten fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nicht herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
die roboter sollen laut plan der nasa
schon lange bevor wir menschen
irgendwann einmal auf dem mars ein
treffen mit ihrer arbeit beginnen als
basis für die produktion der
lebensnotwendigen ressourcen könnte
regolith genutzt werden ein lockeres
pulver aus verwitterten vulkangestein
überall auf dem mars verteilt genauer
gesagt besteht es aus sogenannten
silikaten die sich unter anderem aus
sauerstoff und silizium zusammensetzen
das reguliert befindet sich unter einer
eisenoxid schicht die die oberfläche des
mars so rot erscheinen lässt doch der
abbau von schichten dort ist alles
andere als einfach die gravitation auf
dem mars ist ja deutlich niedriger als
auf unserer erde sie beträgt nämlich nur
38 prozent der schwerkraft unseres
heimatplaneten und das würde die arbeit
der schrift werkzeuge wie beispielsweise
das drücken der baggerschaufel in den
boden fast unmöglich machen
denn das eigengewicht des baggers wäre
auf dem mars zu gering um dieser kraft
entgegenzuwirken zudem müssten die
roboter ja in leichtbauweise angefertigt
werden also es wird noch schwieriger
um sie überhaupt auf den roten planeten
transportiert werden zu können
doch die nasa hat einen prototypen
konstruiert der hoffnung macht eine
maschine namens wasser
das steht für reguliert advanced surface
systems operations roboter seine
bauweise ist wichtig er baut die
gewünschte regolith schicht mit zwei
schaufelräder ab wobei diese sich durch
gegenläufige drehbewegungen
neutralisieren somit stellt die fehlende
schwerkraft kein problem mehr da durch
die arbeit des roboters entsteht dabei
hinter ihm kein tiefes loch sondern er
eine art flachen graben in einem
nächsten schritt soll ressort das
material dann in eine basis bringen
in der es dann weiterverarbeitet wird
auch diese stationen sollen nach angaben
der nasa vollautomatisch laufen und das
reguliert erhitzen dabei entsteht zum
einen wasser das gesammelt wird und als
trinkwasser für mögliche mars risiken
dienen kann doch mit dem gewonnenen
wasser kann noch viel mehr angestellt
werden durch elektrolyse also ich stecke
einfach im plus und minuspol rein und
jage strom hindurch kann daraus sowohl
nämlich wasserstoff als auch sauerstoff
gewonnen werden und diese beiden gase
könnten dann wiederum in einem weiteren
verarbeitungsschritt verflüssigt werden
und somit als treibstoffe
raketentriebwerke den bau doch die nasa
hat eine andere idee
sie will den flüssigen wasserstoff dann
durch kombination mit kohlenstoff zur
methan umwandeln
das dann auch als treibstoff genutzt
werden kann und damit zurück zum
reguliert durch das erhitzen entsteht
neben dem wasser außerdem ein
staubtrockener abfallprodukt dieses soll
von den robotern entsorgt werden und als
ausgangspunkt für den bau von häusern
und straßen dienen diese sollen durch 3d
druck entstehen hammer
diese anlage könnte also einige jahre
bevor die erste besatzung mit dem maß
erreicht ihre arbeit beginnen und somit
systematisch alle notwendigen vorräte
für eine erfolgreiche mission
bereitstellen und das ist alles viel
mehr als reine science fiction
verschiedene ingenieurteams der nasa
sind bereits dabei diese mission diese
vision zur realität werden lassen laut
nasa soll das ganze schon in naher
zukunft verschiedene testläufe
absolvieren zunächst auf der erbe dann
auf dem mond und als großes finale soll
die idee dann irgendwann auf dem mars
selbst realisiert werden wenn es
neuigkeiten dazu gibt dann erfahrt ihr
es natürlich hier und zuerst auf
whatsapp dafür einfach hier klicken und
den newsletter abonnieren und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran